how does it feel to once again be back
in St Louis playing in this prestigious
event
it's pretty exciting like I've never
I've played a few of these people before
playing
with all these amazing players is
definitely exciting and should be a
great experience I mean it's really
exciting because I grew up watching this
event over and over through the years
and I was always really impressed by the
players and how and how how wonderfully
smooth the tournament was ran so I'm
really glad I get to play this year as
well it feels great I mean like I
haven't been in St Louis in a year I
think
um and it's always like really nice to
come here because
it's just like such a welcoming place
it's always nice to participate in the
Juniors I'm really looking forward to it
this year because it's my last year
actually so hopefully I can go out with
a bang and you know uh get like one
really nice good memory out of the event
it's been a while since I play like U.S
Juniors or U.S Championship here
um I believe last time was probably 2019
um use Junior it's just one of the worst
tournaments of my life so
um hoping to make it better uh I I don't
think I've ever played a good U.S
Juniors and it's kind of funny that like
I've won a US Champs but that way they
use Junior so
um I'm just trying to try to like enjoy
my last year here it feels amazing
especially since it's my last time and
I'm just trying to have as much fun as I
can I've been telling myself you know
I'm gonna do something enjoyable every
day even if I lose or even if it's a bad
day I'm gonna try to do something
enjoyable and just make the most I can
out of this trip and this tournament and
my experience here it feels good I've
been here for a few times so it's always
a pleasure coming back it's really
exciting for me because I grew up
watching this event as well and so many
of my role models have either won this
event or played in it numerous times so
yeah it's really exciting for me to be
able to follow in their footsteps and
even compete and meet with them oh it's
a great honor to be back here of course
playing in the junior growth
Championship I was here last May and St
Louis is just one of my favorite places
to be to play chess I'm very excited I'm
excited to play some good games
um I've really been looking forward to
this event
foreign